Prof: Today we have our
first guest lecturer.
I have the pleasure of
introducing you to Dr. Michael
Teitelbaum.
He was an undergraduate at Reed
College where he double majored
in biology and sociology;
that's an interesting
combination, he's Phi Beta Kappa
and at the end of that became a
Rhodes scholar.
How many prospective Rhodes
scholars do we have in the
class?
Then he went to Oxford as a
biologist to study reproductive
biology and his advisor died.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Well first he was
paralyzed for--he died a
horrible slow death,
yes.
Prof: Something bad
happened.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Something terrible
happened.
Prof: Then got into the
statistical and quantitative
aspects of that and then
eventually he got a PhD in
demography itself,
and since then he's come back
to America and he's taught at
Oxford,
and Princeton, and here at Yale.
Unlike most academics,
he actually ventured into the
real world, although I'm not
sure some of these are really
like the real world,
like the U.S. Government.
Dr. Michael Titlebaum:
Yeah, somewhat unreal.
Prof: He was the staff
director of a Select Committee
on Population for the
U.S. House of Representatives
and then was U.S. Commissioner
for the Study of International
Migration and Cooperative
Economic Development,
so that's pretty important.
He's been with the Ford
Foundation,
The Carnegie Endowment for
International Peace,
and he's now with The Alfred
Sloan Foundation where he's been
vice president and in charge of
science and technology programs.
He's been on the advisory
boards at National Academy
Sciences, National Institutes of
Health, American Association for
the Advancement of Science.
He's authored seven books,
but I could only find four:
one, two, three,
four.
So in addition to your reading
packet, which I hope you all
picked up--this is just your
reading for tonight.
In addition to--this is half
his books--five major government
reports, 75 articles,
etc.
One of his major contributions
is what we've--
one of the topics we've just
been--just finished discussing,
he wrote--I think I mentioned
this to you during the lecture
that part of the Princeton
project on Britain,
the book on the British
fertility decline,
there's the author.
And The Times Higher
Education Supplement,
wrote on that book:
"An unsurpassed profusion
of original data presented and
analyzed with clarity all too
often lacking in works of this
kind.
The book is invaluable;
it clarifies and orders the
complex rang of forces,
which underlay the modern
decline in rates of
fertility."
He's also worked on global
environmental issues and
population and resources,
he wrote this,
an environmental book,
is one of the best
investigations.
So, you have the honor,
not only the lecture today,
but he's agreed to come to
dinner and all the students are
invited.
It's going to be at Timothy
Dwight starting at 5:30 and I
know you have other things.
If you can't--we'll probably
have a leisurely--
casual leisurely dinner,
so if you can't get there at
5:30,
come when you can--or if you
have something else afterwards,
come and go.
At TD.
There's some sort of a small
dining room as you leave--as you
come around.
Okay in the last lecture we
discussed the fertility declines
in Europe and Tuesday we
discussed how this fertility
decline--
started discussing--has
continued in Europe and spread
around the world.
I showed you a graph of the
decline in fertility rates
globally.
In the developed countries--so
in the world as a whole,
as you've been told,
the fertility decline has not
been enough to keep the
population from still going up
very rapidly,
we discussed that,
but in Europe,
Japan,
the advanced countries,
the fertility decline has
caused the population to come
down enough,
and these countries are now
facing rather serious problems
of a decline,
a possible decline,
in their population,
certainly a change in behavior
structure and this is what
Michael is an expert on and so
that is what he will discuss
today as soon as I shut up.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Well thank you very much
Dr. Wyman and it's a pleasure
to be here.
I just want to say,
you're a very lucky bunch of
undergraduates to have Robert
Wyman as your professor.
He's a--I've heard him lecture
and I know him and he's a
wonderful academic and scholar.
Going through that list of--
Prof: We give each other
$100 tip.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Going through that list of
publications makes me realize
why my wife has been so annoyed
with me for the 40 years nearly
that we've been married,
because a lot of that work has
had to be done when I wasn't an
academic and that means it comes
out of your hide or out of your
summer holidays,
or weekends,
or evenings,
but it's interesting,
exciting, and wonderful to do,
and I've enjoyed doing it.
I know that you have been
discussing--because I've seen
your prospectus for this
excellent course.
I know you've been discussing
high fertility rates and the
demographic transition and you
know therefore that high
fertility has attracted a great
deal of attention for at least
two centuries and has always
been related to poverty issues,
concerns about poverty,
underdevelopment,
developing countries and so on,
or poverty back in the 1800s
when Malthus was writing,
and also related to concerns
about the environment and so on.
What is less known though is
that, for at least 100 years of
those two centuries,
there's been discussion about
low fertility as a problem as
well.
This has a long and,
I would say,
tumultuous history,
lots of proponents worrying
about it, often very prominent
people in politics or science.
I would say the debates have
been plagued by misunderstanding
and confusion as have the
debates about high fertility,
so there's something about
population that stimulates
misunderstanding and confusion.
Now in general,
low fertility has been linked
to a decline in power.
You have to think about this in
political and economic terms.
National power,
empires, the decline of empires
and so on, but the links have
been made, but it's often very
fuzzy as to what the causal flow
is.
Is the low fertility a cause of
the decline of empires or
decline of national power,
or is it a symptom?
Often the commentators don't
make it very clear what they're
talking about.
Those of you who know the
French debates about these
issues will know that it's a
very prominent feature of French
intellectual discourse going
back into the 1870s,
for example.
The French are hardly alone in
this.
You will find many such
anxieties expressed in Germany
in the 1930s,
in Great Britain,
Sweden, U.S.,
Russia, etc.
More recently,
let's say over the past four
decades or so,
in Eastern Europe,
in Japan, in the U.S.
certainly, and in the Asian
Tigers most recently:
Singapore, Taiwan,
and Korea.
Because it's about power,
national power,
or sub-national power low
fertility has long been closely
tied to political ideology and
to cultural values.
In some cases,
low fertility has even been
used as a tool to achieve
desired social policies.
I want to make one point,
that I hope you'll take away
from this,
which is that the concern about
low fertility has never,
ever, been solely about the
number of warm bodies,
human being warm bodies that
is, but instead it's been
visualized through the lens of
these socio cultural values.
The reason I say it's never
been about warm bodies can be
illustrated there,
because if what I said is not
true there really could never
have been any concern about
fertility since at least 1950.
The world's population,
as you see,
has grown dramatically over
that half century and neither
could there be any concern about
future population demographic
trends because the projections
no matter which variant you take
from the UN all show substantial
growth going forward.
In reality, the fears about low
fertility are also framed in
terms of regional or national,
or religious,
or ethnic or sub-national
populations defined culturally.
I would put it rather crudely,
if I may,
that since the onset of
mortality decline which you've
heard about already,
at least two centuries ago,
there have never been any
shortages of humans.
There have only been perceived
or relative shortages of
particular kinds of humans.
The most critical category is
national groups in these
discussions and then you can get
into language,
or religion,
or the other subgroups.
To give you an example of this
I just want to point out that
when he was Mayor of Paris,
the later President of the
Republic of France,
Jacque Chirac,
he warned about the decline in
the population of France.
This is consistent with French
perspectives that right to left,
all French people think that
there are two few French people
and yet at the same time he
urged the repatriation of Arab
immigrants and the restriction
of future immigration.
I mean now that classically
shows you that it's not about
the number of warm bodies;
it's about the number of French
warm bodies in France.
There is no ideological
uniformity in these things.
I've already said that in
France the range of concerns is
right from the left to the
right, right across political
spectrum.
Democratic thinkers of what you
might call liberal in the U.S.,
or left wing in Europe say,
and of conservative
orientations,
have all expressed concern
about this in one form or
another.
Those are democratic thinkers,
non-democrats such as the
nationalist right in inter-war
Germany and Italy,
and nationalists parties such
as the Front Nacionalé
in France and other European
countries have expressed such
concerns,
as have the authoritarian lefts
of Stalin and Nicolea Ceausescu
in Romania.
There's a whole story about
Romania which I've written
about.
If you want to see a bizarre
situation read about what the
Romanian government did in the
1960s.
On the political right,
low fertility has generally
been seen as a threat to
national power,
imperial power,
or from the point of some with
a more economics orientation,
to the capacity to restrain
wages and the power of unions.
Many on the right have also
expressed alarm about fertility
differentials between social
classes and races,
ethnic groups and so forth,
but frankly such concerns are
subliminal but there in other
political persuasions than the
right.
Meanwhile, as I said,
the political left has often
shared these nationalistic and
strategic concerns.
In the 1930s,
Hitler's Germany adopted very
aggressive pronatalist policies
to raise fertility in Germany
but so did Stalin's USSR,
same time, same place or
different places same time,
same policies in many ways.
Then there were the socialist
states,
I mentioned Ceausescu,
had a very strong pronatalist
policy,
but in the meantime the
People's Republic of China went
from pronatalism to strongly
anti-natalist,
probably the most energetic
fertility reduction policy in
world history,
same country,
same party in control --
taking population very
significantly.
Now, in the West,
the democratic left has
concentrated generally on the
threat posed by low fertility to
their desires to expand and
strengthen the welfare state,
and in fact,
if you look at in 1930s you'll
see a fascinating debate led by
the Myrdal's (prominent
economists,
Nobel laureates later of the
left in Sweden) who promoted
what came to be called the
welfare state to the
conservative parties in Sweden
on the grounds that they needed
to do something to raise
fertility and that was the way
to do it.
If they didn't raise fertility,
there would be no Swedes left
in 50 years or so,
and they actually co-opted the
right successfully into
supporting the welfare state
that they promoted.
What about demographers?
Have they been involved in this
stuff?
Yes, they have including some
very prominent ones.
One reason for this was the
discovery, the development in
the 1930s by demographers of
some very powerful concepts and
techniques.
I don't know if you've actually
studied yet the intrinsic rate
of increase,
net reproduction rate,
total fertility rate,
and demographic projection
models.
All of these being
developed--technologies
developed in the 1930s and these
led to predictions from
demographers that the population
of the United Kingdom,
for example from the 1930s to
the 1960s,
would decline very sharply and
there were some very pathetic
novels and academic books
written with titles like
Twilight of Parenthood,
Race Suicide,
and other such tomes.
That forecast,
using demographic projection
models, that there would be too
few whatever's,
of the relevant group.
Now in some respects these were
flawed predictions,
obviously.
It didn't happen,
and they arose from
misunderstanding because these
were new technologies that had
only recently been understood
and developed and there was a
typical excess of enthusiasm,
academic enthusiasm,
they really thought they had
developed a window into the
distant future.
They could project the
population using intrinsic rates
of increase and projection
models and they could see 50
years into the future.
They thought.
They were wrong.
All of those projections proved
to be empirically wrong.
We know better now because
we've seen they were wrong.
It helps to actually see things
go so badly wrong,
but these same errors of
believing demographic
projections to be forecasts of
future populations are being
made right now as we speak,
mostly by non-demographers.
Demographers have all learned
they can't believe projections
as predictions.
Non-demographers haven't
learned that lesson or don't
want to learn that lesson,
and they use these projections
to forecast decline of the West,
and decline of the Soviet
Union, decline of Russia,
decline of Italy,
whatever category they want to
talk about.
What about--I said there were a
few very distinguished
demographers who also did this?
Yes, the most prominent was the
great French demographer Alfred
Sauvy, a very distinguished man
indeed, probably the dean of
French demographers.
He did this kind of
relationship of low fertility
equals decline for most of his
professional career,
for 40 years basically.
Let me just list for you some
of the events in history that he
attributed to fertility rates
being too low.
He said the decadence of
ancient Athens and then of Rome,
item one.
The failure of France to
industrialize,
the decline of the French Navy
in the nineteenth century,
the collapse of the French army
before the Germans in 1940.
He used very evocative language.
He said, for example,
"The terrible failure of
1940,
more moral than material,
must be linked in part to this
dangerous sclerosis resulting
from low birthrates.
We saw all too often during the
occupation,"
German occupation,
"old men leaning wearily
towards the servile solution.
At the time that the
young," that's the
resistance,
"were taking part in the
national impulse towards
independence and liberty.
This crucial effect of our
senility, is it not a grave
warning?
Depopulation for France carries
with it, fatally,
a general legacy of
decadence."
You see how powerful the
rhetoric can be in this area.
I do not want you to get the
impression that demographers
shared these lifelong concern
about fertility being too low,
to the contrary,
they were not widely shared
among demographers after all the
gloomy forecasts of the 1930s
proved to be wrong.
The past is one of confusion
and anxiety.
What about the future?
I'd say it's likely to be a
future of great
unpredictability.
The truth is that currently we
are in a period of low fertility
rates that are without precedent
in their lowness,
if you will,
their smallness and without
precedent in how widespread they
have become around the world.
Having no precedent we actually
lack any way of knowing if they
will continue at these very low
levels,
if they'll rise somewhat,
perhaps even above the magic
2.11 replacement level,
or could they decline further
to levels such as the league
table leaders with low fertility
which would be surprisingly
enough Italy,
Spain, Hong Kong.
We don't know.
Anybody who tells you they
know, you should not believe,
they have no way of knowing.
We do know that the very low
fertility of 1930s was short
lived but then was followed by a
substantial baby boom in some
countries that had low fertility
in the 1930s and not in others.
All I can say to you is why
don't you all come back for your
fiftieth reunion at Yale in 50
years and we'll have a talk
about whether fertility rates
stayed very low,
went lower, or rose in these
countries that were very low.
That's the only way we're ever
going to know.
This graph will surely be wrong
as a prediction,
I will predict that.
There's an irony here,
we have moved from a society in
which 90% of women have no
effective control over their
fertility to a society in which
90% of women do have effective
control of their fertility,
rational control of their
fertility.
The result is that analysts,
demographers and you,
are less able to rationally
anticipate what they will
collectively do now that they
individually,
rationally have control over
their fertility.
A very wide range of population
projections is plausible,
that's just a narrow range
compared to some you could do if
you wanted to make--
these are quite conservative
assumptions on the high side and
the low side.
Under these kinds of conditions
of really profound uncertainty,
can we offer any cautious
interpretations of historical
experience that might provide us
with some kind of insight into
the future?
Well I'll offer a few and you
can shoot me down if you would
like to do so.
First, I think it's nearly
inevitable that we'll see
populations with much older age
structures, much older age
compositions then those of the
past.
That's the consequence of low
fertility.
Of course if there's a nuclear
catastrophe or some other
catastrophe all bets are off.
None of these projections or
future looks can assume
catastrophe.
The only way to return to the
youthful age structures of the
past would be to have very
substantial fertility increases
to those of the past and to
sustain those very high
fertility rates.
This in turn would apply--would
imply rapid population,
increase ad infinitum.
I think most of you know that
that's not likely to happen.
Now my other point here is that
societies that have very low
fertility rates,
like 1.1 child per woman on
average that you might find in
Italy or Japan,
Japan's a little higher but 1.3
in Japan.
I think it would be
desirable--this is a value
judgment on my part,
it would be desirable for
fertility rates to rise somewhat
to more moderate levels but I
don't think they will ever rise
in those countries to the levels
pre-transition.
The challenge is going to be
find creative mechanisms to
smooth the transition from
younger to older demographic age
structures and to put in place
adaptive mechanisms that will
allow such societies to prosper
over the longer term under these
new conditions.
The second point I'd like to
make is that we are in danger
collectively of making two
errors of demographic
interpretation and these are
both significant errors.
First, we are in danger of
putting undue emphasis upon what
are called period rates.
Have you discussed period rates?
Prof: There's a reading
from the last lecture.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Okay.
We are in danger of focusing on
period rates.
I've just done it myself;
1.1 child per woman for Italy,
even though we know they are
distorted rates.
They're well below the
underlying rates of how many
children the average woman will
have when she finishes her
childbearing,
that's a cohort rate.
Second danger is--and we're
doing it every day,
mis-specifying the category
aged and thereby misconstruing
what demographic aging means.
Let me say a few words about
both of those.
In Italy, Spain,
Greece, Portugal,
Ireland, countries like that in
Europe,
there have been significant
increases in the mean age of
marriage and hence the mean age
of first birth typically.
These are large increases by
demographic standards and they
are large enough to cause
distortions in the period rates
over the time period during
which the mean age of
childbearing is rising.
This is a well known phenomenon
to demographers;
it's not well understood among
political leaderships.
When I was working on The Hill
running a congressional
committee,
I learned not to use the term
'cohort,' because as soon as I
said cohort the Congressman
would say,
'you mean your friends,
your cohort?'
I said 'no, no it's a
generation concept.'
'Oh I don't get it,
don't bother me with the
facts.'
But even the term is
misunderstood.
Given that it's really too easy
to distort,
for that kind of audience if
you want to make the case that
we're all going to hell in a
hand basket to distort these
period rates and say this is
what's going to continue
indefinitely into the future.
Prof: Can you just
say--repeat what period it is.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Period rate--
Prof: Not all of them
have read about it.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Okay, a period rate is--
it is expressed--let's
say--let's take the total
fertility rate which is a period
rate,
it is synthetic in the sense
that it is an attempt to
summarize the fertility behavior
let's say in 2009 of women,
demographers care only about
women by the way,
of women of all ages.
It's the fertility rates of
women 15 to 19,20 to 24;
these are different cohorts as
you can see in 2009.
They're born in different years;
they each have a characteristic
fertility rate by age.
If you sum up the rates of all
of those age groups in a given
year you will get a period rate,
which is an attempt to
summarize the overall fertility
behavior of the entire
population of all ages.
Then we express it,
probably confusingly,
in terms such as 1.1 child per
woman, or 2.1 children per
woman.
It's not actually any real
woman, it's a synthetic woman.
Prof: The best kind.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
The best kind of women
yeah.
If you--another way to imagine
this--imagine you had 1,000
female demographers.
That's a frightening prospect
when you think about it,
and they formed a pact,
they were all age 15,
so they're 15-year-old
demographers and they form a
pact that they will bear
children collectively at the
rate of each age group in that
year that they make the pact
right through their reproductive
lifespan.
At the end of their
reproductive lifespan,
40 say or 45,
they collectively would have an
average children ever born equal
to the total fertility rate for
that year,
but of course that would never
happen.
I mean I'm just trying to give
you an--ask you to imagine what
the rates mean.
The problem with the
rates--well let me say what's
good about the period rates.
They give you a summary of
what's going on in a year or in
a five year period,
that's why it's called a period
rate.
It's a current kind of summary
The cohort rates don't do that,
they tell you how many children
women age 45 today had through
their entire lifespan.
The problem with the period
rates is that they can be
distorted if women delay or
accelerate their childbearing.
Each year if there's a delay
they may end up with the same
number of children when they
finish their childbearing,
but they stretch it out over
more years,
so the annual rates,
the period rates are depressed
therefore.
We know that's happening in
southern Europe,
we know it's not happening in
central Europe,
so low rates in central Europe
are not distorted in this way,
the low rates in southern
Europe are distorted in this
way.
That's probably enough about
period rates.
Now I've said the second
possible error is the
mis-specification by
demographers and others of the
boundaries of the age dependency
category.
Convention, when do you get to
be aged dependent?
The answer 65.
Where did that number come from?
Arbitrary.
Who came up with it?
The people who designed the
Social Security Act of 1935 who
had to decide at what age did a
person qualify for a Social
Security pension.
Why did they say 65?
Well actually initially they
were going to say 70 because
they were copying Bismarck's
social insurance scheme from the
nineteenth century,
and the Bismarck system you got
your state pension at age 70.
It was a time of mass
unemployment and so there was a
desire to encourage older
workers to leave the work force
to make room for unemployed
younger workers,
so they moved it down by five
years, 65.
It's been that way in the
statistics, in the data,
ever since.
Demographers have not adjusted
to the reality that the meaning
of 65 in 1935 was very different
from the meaning of 65 in 2005
or 2009.
That's a problem because we
will spend a lot of time
calculating to the third decimal
place the aged dependency ratio
and yet we know that the meaning
of the boundary between working
age and aged dependency is
increasingly out of touch with
reality.
The same is true,
by the way, of the young
dependency ratio,
youthful dependency ratio,
which is usually set at age 15
or 19 on grounds that after that
people become productive labor
force people like you.
That's all changed too but we
still stick to these boundaries
and we're misleading ourselves
and everyone else I'm afraid by
doing that.
There are a lot of alternatives
to this.
I won't go into them but one
obvious possibility would be to
shift the age boundaries upward
for both the youthful and the
older boundaries,
say to 20 years and 70 years,
rather than 15 and 65 that
would make sense.
You'd want to keep the old
series as well because you would
want to have some comparability
over time,
but to have an alternative
ratio would be useful.
Another possibility would be to
fix the number of years of
remaining life expectancy rather
than the age,
the absolute age as the
boundary between aged dependency
and working age.
Now let me talk a bit about
policy responses to very low
fertility.
There are basically two basic
types of policy responses that
have been strongly urged.
First measures to increase
fertility, that's a pretty
obvious and direct one,
and second measures to adapt to
low fertility over the longer
term.
I am not embracing any of these
recommendations but I do want to
give you the analytic
possibilities that might--that
have been put forward.
First, and this will offend
most of you, it has been urged
and implemented in some
countries to limit access to
fertility control.
If you banned contraception,
abortion, etc.,
sterilization,
fertility rates would go up.
That's basically what Ceausescu
in Romania did in 1966.
This would be probably
unworkable in a liberal
democracy.
Romania was not a liberal
democracy to say the least,
and it would be unacceptable in
many other ways.
It would probably result in a
revolution in the United States,
but that's analytically a
possibility.
Second, economic incentives to
encourage higher fertility and
these have come in many forms in
the past.
How about cash bonuses for
bearing a child?
Or allowances,
annual payments per child you
have in the family,
from the government,
or tax preferences to people
with children,
those are part of U.S.
tax law, of course.
These can be flat,
meaning each child is treated
the same in terms of the amount
of bonus or tax incentive,
or they can be
"progressive"--
I guess you put that in
quotes--with increasing amounts
per--
for later births.
You might give no incentive for
the first birth but a big
incentive for the third birth,
for example.
You could give 'in-kind'
benefits.
For example,
in much of Eastern Europe,
families with more than two
children had access to larger
and preferential flats,
preferred flats,
government flats.
They got preference in that way
or subsidized housing,
or you could give early
retirement bonuses to people.
You could say,
well a woman who has three or
more children can retire at age
55 instead of 65,
that would be an incentive.
In both the Soviet Union in the
1930s and in Nazi Germany in the
1930s,
women got prizes,
gold medals,
mother heroine awards,
gold medals for eight or more
children,
for example,
in the Soviet Union.
You could counterweight
existing dis-incentives to large
families for example,
by facilitating female labor
force participation for women
who have children in various
ways;
the French Crèche System
which is a government financed
early childhood,
before the schools start,
system of childcare is an
example of doing that.
The Swedish government has lots
of policies of this kind.
Those are benign examples but
there are some harsh examples.
You could take measures to
deter female labor force
participation on grounds that
you think it conflicts with
maternal behavior.
Now among Western countries,
there have really been only a
few that have adopted explicitly
pronatalist policies of these
kinds.
France, Luxemburg,
Greece, Quebec come to mind,
although other countries have
policies they do not describe as
pronatalist policies,
they say they're social
policies, but they have the
implicit effect of being
pronatalist and they don't
acknowledge that typically.
In France there have been
proposals never adopted for an
official maternal wage,
and it's called that,
in which mothers who stay at
home with young children would
get monthly payments from the
government,
they get paid to be mothers
that would be calculated in
those proposals at about 25% of
the prevailing wage for employed
women.
In the socialist countries,
former socialist countries of
eastern Europe,
there were lots of these
policies.
They've all disappeared or
almost all have disappeared
since the fall of the communist
system,
but those countries had child
allowances,
birth bonuses,
maternity leave at full pay for
five months,
paid leave until the child is
three years of age,
and substantial subsidies and
grants in kind.
The only non-Western low
fertility country that's pursued
this kind of policy,
that I'm familiar with it so
far at least,
but there will be others almost
surely,
is Singapore.
Singapore has embraced strong
pronatalist policies and there
have been some modest ones in
Korea, Thailand,
and Malaysia.
In Singapore too they have
policies about encouraging
highly educated young men and
women to meet each other,
they have dating services,
they want them to meet each
other and marry and have
children,
which always causes amusement
outside of Singapore.
They don't think it's funny;
they think it's perfectly
sensible.
It's fair to say that the
impacts of these policies on
fertility are probably there,
but they're small impacts.
In some countries they were
very expensive policies as well,
but they didn't have much
impact.
If you tried to do the kinds of
things that eastern European
socialist countries did in the
1980s proportionately in Western
countries the costs would be
enormous,
1/3 to 1/2 of average wages for
a family with two or three
children for example;
the cost would be very large.
Now what about measures to
adapt to low fertility over the
long term?
Well, first it's easier to
adapt if the shifts are gradual,
so very low fertility countries
having dramatic shifts in the
age structure,
it makes it much harder for
them.
Then I've already mentioned the
question of the boundaries
between dependency and so on,
I won't repeat that,
but it's fair to say that the
elderly dependent population,
however defined,
is going to cost more than the
youthful dependent population,
mainly because of healthcare.
Education is the main public
investment in youthful dependent
population, the rest of the
costs of those children are
borne by families.
When it comes to the aged
dependent population the
families are no longer paying
the costs, and the healthcare
costs are very high and rising.
Here I would have to say that,
of the industrialized countries
of the West, the U.S.
has the largest problem in this
regard.
Not because it has the oldest
age structure or the most
rapidly growing elderly
population,
but because it is politically
incapable of controlling it's
expenditure on healthcare and
that's a generic problem in the
society,
but it has special import for
the elderly age structure.
What could governments do?
Well they could modify the
terms of the social pension
provisions,
they could shift the effective
age of retirement,
they could privatize part of
the pension system,
they could subject pension
benefits of well off retirees to
substantial income taxation.
But, in fact,
the politics of pension policy
in most of these countries have
operated in the other direction,
in the opposite direction.
Most countries,
if anything,
have taken measures to lower
the pension age until recently
when they've started gradually
now to reverse the lowering of
pension ages that they engaged
in,
in the 1960s and 1970s.
As far as the youthful
population is concerned,
it's going to be smaller with
these low fertility populations.
Well, one could certainly
convert age related facilities,
such as schools,
for other purposes,
and going forward,
it would make a lot of sense to
design new schools in a flexible
way so they're easier to convert
for other purposes,
which leads me finally to
immigration.
Immigration is often put
forward as a way to deal with an
aging population.
The truth is that the potential
pool of immigrants to low
fertility countries,
the potential pool,
is very large and it could
easily be tapped.
In fact, many of these
countries are having problems
restraining the flow which is
exceeding what they would like
it to be.
It would be quite simple for a
low fertility country,
any one of the ones I've
mentioned,
to simply augment their
populations by allowing
additional immigration.
That sounds a lot easier than
changing the pension system and
then all the other systems.
Now let me take you back to my
point about concerns about low
fertility not being about the
number of warm bodies,
but about the numbers defined
as part of the nation or other
ethnic or cultural group,
so that's the paradox.
Under conditions of very low
fertility,
substantial immigration would
produce very rapid
transformation of the
composition of a population
socio-culturally defined,
and historically such rapid
changes have led to passionate
public opposition.
The irony here is that,
while you might think,
as an analyst,
sitting here in lecture room at
Yale that why not just have more
warm bodies immigrate and
that'll take care of the issue.
It's exactly in a low fertility
setting that the public
opposition is strongest to
increased or substantial
immigration.
There are some examples in
which immigration can be of--
by people who are defined as
part of,
or similar to,
the indigenous population,
and in those cases,
there's less--typically less
opposition and I can give you a
few examples.
Like the post war migration of
East Germans to West Germany,
for example.
Or the Germans,
so called Germans --
the Volga Germans--from Russia
to Germany which turned out to
be quite controversial,
but they were defined as
Germans returning home even
though they're ancestors had
left 300 years earlier.
The Pied Noir's to France after
the collapse of the French
Empire, in Africa mostly;
the "return"-- think
about that, the
"return"
of Jews from North Africa to
the new state of Israel;
of Italians or Italian
Argentineans rather,
to Italy;
of Japanese origin people,
the Nisei from Brazil and Peru
to Japan;
of Angolan colonial settlers to
Portugal, so there are examples
of this kind of migration being
less controversial.
I think one should also say
that moderate levels of
immigration do not appear to be
all that controversial.
This is not a question of
people being passionately
against immigration,
but it's a question of
quantity.
This will lead me,
if I can get this to move
forward--here's a Jacque Chirac
quote which I meant to show you,
I'll let you read it.
You see Chirac was saying that
in 2004,--we already know what
the population was in 2004--but
that Europe would be empty in
2004.
He said that in 1984 and one
thing the demographers have
learned is never make a
prediction over a time span in
which you might still be alive
because you will probably always
be wrong;
Chirac was clearly wrong.
What I want to talk about is a
study,
and this will be my last
section here,
a study of the question of
substituting immigration for
missed fertility in low
fertility societies.
There was a study done by the
United Nations Population
Division in 2000.
It asked the question,
how many immigrants would be
needed to compensate for low
fertility in Europe?
The answer was: A lot.
This was no surprise to the UN
Population Division or to
demographers,
but it was a surprise to The
New York Times,
which in 2001 ran this
story--or 2000 I guess it is,
back in January 2000 ran this
story picked up by The Herald
Tribune in Paris and so on,
about this study.
I know a little bit about the
history of why it was published
on the 2^(nd) of January 2000,
which I can tell you because
it's a story about how the press
works.
The study had been filed months
before by the journalist Barbara
Croset,
and was literally filed in a
file cabinet,
had not been published,
and then on the second of
January,
day after New Year's,
slow news day,
nothing was happening,
the editor on duty said,
'oh we have that story from six
months ago let's just throw that
in the paper.'
They put it in the paper,
it had already been written and
edited,
and notice the headline here,
the subhead,
'It's The American Way,' you
can imagine how this appealed to
the nationalists in various
European countries.
Europe stares at a future built
by immigrants,
it's the American way.
The reaction was described to
me by the head of the UN
population division in one word.
He said it was
"mayhem."
They started to get calls
almost immediately from almost
every newspaper in Europe.
The Secretary General of the
United Nations got calls from
most European countries,
from the governments,
and not surprisingly the
Secretary General's office
called over to the Population
Division and said,
'could you please send us the
study.'
The truth is,
there was no study.
They had done some back of the
envelope calculations and had
done a one page talking point
thing for a General Assembly
meeting that they thought it
might come up at.
What they did was a press
release that was I think two
pages,
summarizing the back of the
envelope calculations,
and within a few days Le
Monde story here,
here's the press release.
Here's Le Monde,
I think, and Le Monde
actually dropped the question
mark at the end of the title of
the press release.
You see there,
the press release says,
"Replacement Migration,
Is It A Solution To Declining
And Aging Populations?"
and Le Monde translated
it as 'a solution to declining,
etc., populations.'
There was suddenly a big story
in Europe,
here we have Le Figaro,
the report that alarmed Europe,
it was translated--I think
there's an Economist
article here.
Here's a cartoon from
Figaro saying,
what's the distance from Europe
to the United Nations,
etc., a man and a woman talking
over the--
about that.
Here's The Economist,
fewer and wrinklier Europeans--
all the major German newspapers
had articles,
Belgium, Spanish,
Italian, the French TV main
channel sent crews to the UN to
interview the authors of the
study.
There was still no study.
All there was was that press
release that you saw before.
Well for some reason the
Secretary General took the view
that they should now do the
study and they did the study,
and unfortunately what happened
was that the press in Europe
interpreted the UN study or the
press release as the UN
recommendation to European
countries to admit more
immigrants.
"The United Nations is
preparing a new report which
will argue that Europe may need
to accept many more migrants
over the next 50 years to
maintain population levels and
the size of its workforce."
It's not--they did do the
study, very quickly.
It's not what the study did.
This is an inventory of all the
articles that were published
after the press release.
What did they actually find?
Well what they did were
hypothetical scenarios to 2050
and they asked the following
questions among others,
how many immigrants would key
countries need to prevent
decline in the total population,
assuming that their projections
on fertility were accurate,
to hold constant the population
15 to 65,
there we are again with those
15 and 65 age boundaries,
and to hold constant what they
call the potential support ratio
which they defined as the ratio
of people of working age,
meaning 15 to 64 to those who
are aged dependent,
meaning 65 and over.
For the last,
which was in a way the most
important one,
here were the numbers they came
up with: that Germany would need
188 million immigrants by 2050,
at which point 80% of the
population within the boundaries
of Germany would be represented
by those immigrants and their
offspring.
Italy would need 120 million,
and you see the percentages
here,
always 4/5^(ths) of the
population would be accounted
for by immigrants and their
offspring.
The U.S., even the U.S.
which would need 593 million
immigrants would be at 73% even
with its higher fertility rates.
The paradox here is that if you
combine low fertility with high
immigration,
from an economic view or let's
say our Yale undergraduate
perspective,
immigrants or substitutes are
complements,
they're workers,
they have skills,
they bring skills,
they pay taxes,
they subsidize retirement for
older residents.
But the public view is that
immigrants are human beings,
that they have cultures,
religions,
politics, languages,
so if fertility is low,
immigration is less acceptable
to public's than if fertility is
high or higher.
Meanwhile, elites like us,
take that more economic
perspective.
I think probably if we did a
survey of this group we would be
more positive about increasing
immigration then would the
public at large.
The outcomes of this are really
unknowable.
There's been a lot of heat,
there hasn't been a lot of
light about international
migration.
The data are weak,
fertility data are much better,
mortality data are the best
demographic data,
fertility data are the second
best,
migration data are by far the
worst.
They are very weak,
but we think there are about
200 million international
migrants around now and that
it's gone up about 2/3^(rds) in
15 years,
increasing at about 2.3 million
per year.
If you put them all together
where do they fit?
200 million would be the fifth
largest population in the world,
so it's a non-trivial number,
but it's a very small fraction
of the world's population,
like 3% or less.
We have tens of millions of
people migrating,
but overwhelmingly,
the majority of people do not
migrate,
so just keep all of those
paradoxes in your head about
international migration.
In absolute terms,
the U.S.
has the largest number of
foreign-born people at 35
million in 2000,
and The Russian Federation is
next.
Here, if you can read that,
I guess you can,
you see the U.S.
at the top there,
The Russian Federation and then
the other countries are a lot
smaller in terms of foreign-born
residents.
If you look though at the
percent of the population you
get a different list then the
one I just showed you of the
different league table .
The Persian Gulf states have
the highest percentage of the
populations who are immigrants
or international migrants.
Largely because they have
substantial numbers,
small compared to the U.S.,
but substantial numbers of
international migrants of the
base of a very small indigenous
population.
Most of their migrants are
temporary workers;
they are not immigrants in the
sense that they're allowed to
stay permanently.
You have 3/4^(ths) of the
populations of the United Arab
Emirates and the Qatar who are
foreign born and more than half
in Kuwait.
I say here that Israel and
Jordan are about 40%,
it depends on how you define
the Palestinians in Jordan,
but if you call them
international migrants then it's
40% or so in Jordan.
Then you can find a few
European countries but they're
tiny,
like Lichtenstein,
that have high percentages of
foreign born people,
but generally speaking,
the highest percentages are in
small countries and here's the
league table there.
I don't know if you can read
it, United Arab Emirates,
Kuwait, Jordan,
Israel, Singapore,
Oman,
Estonia, Saudi Arabia,
Latvia, Switzerland,
Australia, New Zealand,
Gabon, and Canada.
You see the big countries don't
by and large appear in that
league table .
If you look at countries that
have 50 million or more,
so we're starting about--we're
starting to talk about
significant population of
countries,
the percent of foreign born
exceeds 10% in only three such
countries,
in the Ukraine,
in the U.S.,
and in France.
The Russian Federation and
Germany are getting--are pretty
close so we should include them
probably, but there aren't many
others that are above 5%.
I've already said that low
fertility might imply increasing
immigration and there are
plausible arguments about--
in favor of that to meet the
labor force needs that employers
say they have,
as there's more economic
integration,
more international migration is
inevitable,
and immigrants can arguably
finance unsustainable pension
systems,
pay as you earn pension systems.
There are equally plausible
counterarguments,
and you're just going to have
to decide for yourself.
I don't think anyone can
convince you one way or another
of what's right here,
or what's the proper mindset.
One argument here would be that
low fertility rates are likely
going to be temporary,
that public opposition will
prevent an increase of
international migration to very
high levels and that these pay
as you earn pension systems are
going to be restructured,
and I am firmly on the fence on
this.
I will sit uncomfortably on the
fence as long as I can stand it.
It's painful to sit on the
fence, but in this case I don't
think there's a clear correct
position on these things.
Here are summary and
conclusions: very low fertility
now is widespread and it's
continuing to spread.
I think--the last I looked and
don't quote me on this,
but last I looked if you don't
include China because China
tilts everything,
it's 20% of the world's
population,
so let's be conservative and
not include China,
which does have below
replacement in fertility.
Without China,
40% of the world's population
now lives in countries with
below replacement fertility and
rising.
With China, 60% of the world's
population live in such
countries.
In the past we know that these
low fertility rates,
in fact, not as low as some of
the rates we see today,
have led to exaggerated alarm
and to nationalist responses.
Fertility rates could rise in
the future, there's nothing to
stop them.
Most sociologists,
anthropologists,
and demographers don't think
they will, but they have no way
of knowing.
I don't think they will,
but I could easily be wrong.
It's hard to increase fertility
rates via policy in liberal
democracies.
Increased immigration is often
invoked as a solution to the
problems resulting from very low
fertility but it's not very
effective,
and it's likely to stimulate
its own passionate opposition.
My bottom line is,
and I'll stop with this,
that adaptive societies,
societies that are capable,
flexible enough to adapt to
changing age structures,
up and down and sideways,
are likely to fare the best in
the future.
Thank you.
Prof: I think we have
time to take questions--anybody
has one?
Dr. Michael Tietelbaum:
There have got to be some
questions because I didn't
explain some things that I just
asserted.
Prof: Let me just start
off--and this is a biggee.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Okay.
Prof: I know there are
whole lectures on this.
There's bunches of theories,
I was going to make the
question more elaborate but
let's make it simple.
What do you think is causing
this very low fertility in Japan
and Singapore?
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
How long do we have?
There are a whole range of
theories about this.
There's a whole theoretical
structure called the second
demographic transition theory
which explains low fertility on
grounds of secularization of
societies,
the collapse of religious
social control over behavior
which relates heavily to
marriage and childbearing,
of the rising labor force
participation of women,
and women's labor force
participation being in conflict
with fertility and childbearing
and child rearing,
and a whole range of other
things that you might just
characterize as modernization.
From this point of view
theoretically,
low fertility is permanent and
inevitable in advanced
societies.
That no society of that kind is
going to ever again approach--
well they would--I don't know
if they would say this,
but they might,
would not ever exceed
replacement level and you'll
have high percentages of women
who will be childless throughout
their lives,
low marriage rates,
why should anybody bother
getting married when there's no
problem in cohabiting without
being married socially,
culturally, and legally if all
the benefits of marriage can be
accrued without needing to get
married,
why bother.
You actually see that,
especially in the Nordic
countries,
where very high percentages of
the population,
again of women,
we can look at men too but
women are the important
fertility carriers if you will.
Very high percentages of women
age 30 are never married and
don't look like they ever will
get married,
very high rates of
cohabitation,
and in the case of Sweden
fertility has been rising from
low levels under those
circumstances,
which is posing some
theoretical problems for the
proponents of the second
demographic transition.
We can't explain things like
this.
Life is too complicated,
and collective fertility
behavior is too complicated to
explain things like this.
If you look at Japan,
for example,
in Japan you have very low
rates of marriage among women in
their 20s.
It looks like Sweden in terms
of marriage behavior,
but there's a huge difference
in the percentage of births in
Japan versus Sweden that are
outside of marriage.
If I remember correctly,
it's like 2% of births in Japan
are outside of marriage and in
Sweden it's almost 50% of births
are outside marriage,
so you have the same marriage
behavior roughly,
but higher fertility
collectively in Sweden then you
do in Japan.
Italy, European country,
looks more like Japan in this
respect then it looks like
Sweden or Germany.
Student:  In the media,
this isn't as much of the
crisis that you talk about it
being,
or at least in America you hear
more about terrorism or the war,
health.
Within the government how much
of a big issue is this and at
what time in history is it
prioritized?
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Well the U.S.
has high fertility by the
standards of its peer countries.
It's very close to replacement
level to--last time I looked it
was 2.0 versus 2.1.
It was one 1.1 or so in Italy,
1.3 in Japan,
so there's less concern here
than there is in--among
political elites in other
countries.
What the U.S.
does have that most of them
don't have, however,
is a very large baby boom
generation.
The U.S.
had a big baby boom,
you've probably discussed this
in previous lectures,
or you will.
The U.S., Canada,
Australia, and New Zealand
really were the four baby boom
countries post World War II.
In the case of the U.S.,
fertility went from below
replacement level to 3.7,
doubled essentially.
It peaked in 1957 and started
declining sharply in 1965 but
there was a period--
the so called baby boom
generation,
if you will,
1947 birth to 1965,
who are now reaching the
statutory retirement age and
that bulge is going to rapidly
increase the proportion of the
population in that post 65 age
group for about 20 years because
it's just aging its way through
the age structure.
Given that the U.S.
government has proven itself
incapable of getting control
over health care expenditures
that will be a major crisis for
the Medicare system.
I can predict that without any
doubt whatever.
I don't know what's going to
happen, how it will be handled;
I just know it's going to be a
major crisis.
Yes, ma'am?
Student:  Could you
speak briefly to--
could you provide a response to
theorists who would argue that
widespread moderate decline--
or moderate to severe decline
in populations is actually,
isn't addressing social and
environmental concerns and that
kind of thing?
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Yes.
I have a firmly on the fence
moderate position on these
things.
I think both rapid population
growth and rapid population
decline are problematic for
societies.
There are too many things tied
to age in these societies like
public provision of schools
versus healthcare and other
things that rapid shifts will
cause problems.
I think I alluded to this;
it's easier for societies to
adjust to change if it's slower
in general.
Whether it would be desirable
as some environmentalist's think
for the population of the world
to decline sharply from where it
is,
six point some billion to
whatever they think the carrying
capacity of the earth is,
and that's a highly speculative
calculation of course is another
matter and I don't think anybody
can really resolve those
debates.
People feel very strongly in
both directions about those
sorts of arguments.
I would say myself that the
optimal trajectory would be
fertility rates,
plus or minus 10%,
15% of replacement level,
not 50% above,
not 50% below,
not fluctuating a lot because
if they fluctuate a lot it
causes all kinds of oscillations
in the age structure over 75 or
100 years,
and those are problematic for
societies but moderation in all
things is probably a good a
maxim for these kinds of long
lived,
slow changing but powerful.
They're--demography is like--I
think of demography as being
like the tectonic plates of the
earth,
it's moving very slowly by the
standards of elections or
economic collapses,
or economic booms,
very slowly but huge force
behind it and huge momentum
behind it too,
so you don't want to get in the
way of tectonic plates if you
can avoid it.
I saw another hand, yes sir?
Student:  From a policy
perspective,
I guess specifically for the
U.S., are all warm American
bodies equal or do you take into
consideration economic
circumstances or anything else?
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
From whose perspective?
Student:  The
government's or whoever's
working on this currently.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Well the government
doesn't have a brain.
I mean the government--
Student:  In your
perspective, are all warm bodies
equal or-- Dr.
Michael Teitelbaum:
I would say it depends on
the economy.
If you had to choose,
this is a personal
interpretation,
it's not a fact,
if you had to choose let's say
between a group of very highly
skilled immigrants or a group of
very low skilled,
let's say illiterate
immigrants, and they were moving
into society where the--
most of the population was
illiterate then it wouldn't--
the illiterate immigrant
population would not be a
serious issue really,
but if they're moving into a
society in which you have to be
literate in order to have any
chance of economic
sustainability and advancement,
it would not be a good idea to
import large numbers of people
who are not going to make it in
that society.
It's a question of both the
nature and characteristics of
the immigrants and the nature
and characteristics of the
economy and society into which
they're moving.
Governments--if you ask me what
is the position of the U.S.
or British government on this,
they don't really have one.
It's just the pushing and
shoving of different interest
groups and wherever the vectors
of pushing and shoving end up is
what the government policy is,
but it's not necessarily
thought through in a kind of
logical way.
I think I saw one other hand.
We're running out of time.
Prof: Time's up.
Dr. Michael Teitelbaum:
Okay, good.
>